du changement pour ses 30 ans la clé de
saint pierre va entrer en chantier une
grande rénovation paysagère pour
revégétaliser le quartier l'an courtois
de 6000 habitants l'objectif réinvestir
près de 20% de la surface public du
quartier on arrivait à améliorer la
verità lisation et ainsi de permettre au
quartier non seulement de respirer mais
de d'être de plus en plus frais pourquoi
parce qu'en fait tout ce qui est béton
va réchauffer le coeur de ville pour ce
faire deux ans de travaux sont
nécessaires les opérations vont se
concentrer principalement autour de la
place de paris du collège de la clé
saint-pierre et de l'école jean-monnet
plantation de plus d'une centaine
d'arbres nouvel espace de brumisation
solutions de stationnement et
sécurisation sont prévus dans le projet
lapassade paris un moment très fort avec
chutes arrière la rue d'athènes et la
rue du luxembourg qui voit ta ménagement
6 pour nos commerces on va structurer
des terrasses que nous commerçons puisse
exercer l'été de manière agréable on va
vers dire la place gardé notre fontaine
puisque l'eau est un élément essentiel
après on va avoir tout l'aménagement
devant le collège et à côté de l'école
pour être plus de stationnement nous
allons installer une aire de jeu on
appelle les fitness aujourd'hui ce qu'il
ya une attente de la population pour
faire du sport en extérieur voilà sans
aller forcément dans un club la
réalisation de pistes cyclables et
l'embellissement de deux ronds points
aux couleurs djo sont au programme
également de la rénovation
car le projet se fera en parallèle d'un
autre grand dossier l'aménagement de la
colline d'elancourt qui accueillera les
épreuves de vtt de paris 2024 ces
travaux seront effectués par soli deo la
société de livraison des ouvrages
olympique le projet de l'aménagement la
colline et la course et la conservation
d'une piste olympique pour pouvoir
accueillir
dans le futur de nouvelles compétitions
ainsi possible mais le développement
d'un parc sur la colline un parc de
loisirs et un parc sportif pour pour un
usage diversifiée des changements
conséquents pour la clé de saint pierre
que la ville a présenté samedi 21 mai
aux habitants lors de l'événement mon
quartier demain les quartiers déjà
végétalisée mêlant battre et à rentrer
plus de végétaux dans le quartier et
franchement ça va bien ça va amener de
la végétalisation et puis ça de la
sécurité aussi il a aussi permis de
prendre de vitesse c'est un beau
quartier qui a du potentiel mais je
pense que ya pas mal de choses qui ont
besoin de rénovations et est rafraîchie
sur le projet là c'est intéressant de
pouvoir après à la rai et escales et
faire et rajouter des espaces verts
aménagés je pensais promo d'un coût
total du projet 4 millions d'euros
subventionnés à 70 % par la région ile
de france le département des yvelines et
saint quentin en yvelines fin des
travaux prévue au premier semestre 2024